[Music]
they look like something out of an
indiana jones movie
bridges made out of living trees
this is nongriet a remote village in
northeastern india where locals have
been growing bridges for hundreds of
years
[Music]
the head of the village
he's lived here his whole life since
1952.
[Music]
[Music]
to get the roots to grow into a bridge
across water they use wire and old tree
trunks to guide their path
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
see
[Music]
there's a world-renowned topiary garden
in the tiny town of bishopville south
carolina and that garden was created by
this man
a man named pearl
[Music]
i'm prairie frye
and this is my garden
[Music]
pearl started the garden in 1981 with
the goal of winning yard of the month
from the local garden club i went to a
neighborhood to buy a house and the
reason they didn't want to sell me a
house they said
i wouldn't keep her behind there was a
stereotype at the time that
african-americans didn't keep up their
yards
so i figured if i did one year out of
the month and the person that made that
statement could understand you can't
judge people by one person
[Music]
once i got you out of the month people
couldn't believe it
pearl now has over 300 plants
most of which were throwaways that came
from the recycling bin at a local
nursery i don't water i don't spray i
don't feel like i use no chemicals it's
all natural it's all pretty well done
organically
some of my tallest plant that was
recycled is around 30 feet
so many people drove by pearl's house to
see his garden that he opened it up to
the public peter looks like a sheep
i would say about ten thousand people
visiting my garden every year what else
do you want to look at
people come from all over the world and
see it
i had people from australia japan
korea
i want to share it because so many
people came out and wanted to see it
he very seldom see something
got out so simple and make an impact
that this god has made
the garden is about love
and the last thing you see before you
leave my garden
is love peace and good
[Music]
the redwood forest is a very special
place
it's the darkest forest on earth
the trees are so tall they create their
own shadows
and in those shadows there are a lot of
secrets
[Music]
my name is dave cutie i'm a docent here
at henry cowell redwood state park
i consider myself kind of a volunteer
naturalist and redwood researcher
before coming to henry cowell i was a
engineer in silicon valley but i just
love the redwoods
i've always been an outdoor kind of
person
i've been coming here for 40 years
i come so often now i i swear i could
almost tell when a single branch fell
these are the coastal redwood sequoia
sempervirens it is the tallest tree on
earth by species
their wood is very very interesting it's
red in color
it's very complex genetically and you
can have some that are not like all the
others
albino redwoods have been called ghosts
of the
forest have found 13 albinos in this
park
and not very many not when you consider
there's 2 million redwood trees out
there
i really know albinos i know where they
all are and i continue to look for more
albino redwoods have a very very
soft nature they aren't as structurally
sound as a normal redwood
and we keep trying to understand why
they form here
when we first started
looking at these things we said okay
they're genetically different but it
could be contamination so we have done
some testing found that these guys
actually collect more nickel than these
guys
nickel would normally kill chlorophyll
but the albino redwood doesn't have any
chlorophyll so it doesn't hurt it at all
so where's the source of nickel well
we're on a railroad
some researchers think it is acting like
a liver filtering out the toxic
components protecting the rest of the
forest
[Music]
when i first started here i started
telling everybody where they were and
then i started finding pieces of albino
redwood on the ground
people would go and touch and fold and
break off pieces and i realized that i
couldn't do that i could not be open
with people because they were going to
go in and destroy it so
their location has been kept secret
redwoods are treasure of the earth they
really are
and the more you study them the more you
realize how unique they are and how
adaptable they are
part of the fascination of the redwood
forest is its diversity
i am continuing to be fascinated by what
i see
[Music]
this is the story of a plant
but not just any plant it is the story
of a plant that long long ago once ruled
the world
a plant that today
is the very last of its kind
it's this plant behind me encephalatus
woodyi e woody eye for short and i've
been looking after it for over 20 years
it was named for british botanist john
medley wood who in 1895 discovered it
growing on a hillside on the coast of
south africa the strange handsome plant
caught his eye and he carefully removed
a small portion of it and had it shipped
all the way to london to hear kew
gardens where it's been for the last 117
years but its history goes
much
much further back
you see encephalitis woody eye is what
is known as a cycad
and sonicards have been around for 300
million years as the millennium rolled
on cycads flourished providing shade for
triceratops a perch for pterodactyls and
a tasty snack for brontosauruses at one
point during the jurassic cycads made up
20
of all the plants on earth and covered
every corner of the globe
but
the good times couldn't last forever
the dinosaurs went extinct
ice ages came and went
new modern plants like conifers and
fruit trees started pushing cycads out
and the once proud population of e-woody
eyes were reduced and reduced and
reduced
until there was possibly only one left
one single solitary e-woody eye growing
quietly on a hillside which brings us
right back to john medley wood
at the time he had no way of knowing
just how rare his discovery was
but expedition after expedition in
search of more e woody eye have proved
fruitless you see
cycads are dioecious meaning you need
separate male and female plants to
create a new one and this one happens to
be a male a true lonely bachelor if a
female mate cannot be found it really
will be the last of its kind
to this day researchers are still
looking after all
it's a big world
and might just be a chance
[Music]
in the meantime he'll have me to keep
him company